it is time for cruise news your
king-sized good news burrito packed with
extra good news beans and with me at the
desk my trusty co-pilot ross matthews hi
everybody
and we have a dynamic duo with us today
he is an snl alum actor podcast host and
comedian with stand-up shows coming this
spring at arlington improv it's finesse
mitchell
hello everyone
and she is an emmy nominated actress
comedian mother entrepreneur and naacp
award nominee
congratulations kim congrats
just announced
yes just announced uh me and sherry
shepherd uh just got nominated our
podcast two funny mamas uh for an
uh image awards please don't vote
who got the purple note i mean yellow i
was like somebody should tell me about
the little purple number we were dming
each other you know what i'm saying no
we were not he walked out like like no
ross this is how you wear a purple suit
i'm taking notes big shout out to
sebastian cruz for hooking me up he's a
buddy out of south florida i love that
suit sebastian you are
so awesome so you look hot i look like
barney
you know like a big ball the whole hole
i killed
don't say that about my friend you're
hot yes you are i've been knowing you a
long time i was just about to say that
too you know i've been
and he finally grew up like he looked
like a grown man finally you think so i
finally caught your eye kim
this is the romance storyline we did not
see coming
two funny moments
hi all right should we hit the headlines
guys yeah oh yes
all right first up we have got some
fresh kim kanye pete davidson news okay
they love this 2022 thing you didn't
know you needed the blog she knows
reports that kanye's got a song out it's
brand new with some fighting words for
pete davidson but allegedly pete finds
it hilarious
the lyrics are god saved me from that
crash so i can beat pete davidson's
you-know-what
what problems with crap he didn't say
you know what
exactly finesse allegedly pete never
wants to feud with kanye because that's
the dad of kim's kids plus he expected
to be referenced in one of his songs
sooner or later discuss oh
right are you into this i i absolutely
love it we knew kanye was going to do
this yeah i mean did we expect less no
no and i think pete absolutely loves it
he's happy about it the thing is i think
he's a little afraid just a little bit
pete yes pete's a little afraid really
yes it's but he's not afraid of kanye
he's afraid of kanye's fans oh i'm just
saying oh god that turned dark turned on
right oh my god one minute i'm like oh
this is so fun the next one i'm like
[Applause]
i do get so excited though when there's
just a little teeny celebrity beef it's
my second
favorite kind of beef after hamburger
it's like when celebrities start going
at each other and i have to say uh one
time i told you i had gone to the
kardashian christmas party before okay
it's one of my best things i've ever
done in my entire life and i bring it up
every chance i can and i was behind
kanye west in the buffet line and i
remember thinking to myself ross if you
cut in front of him he could write a rap
song about you
that's like the dream to happen so you
know pete davidson fan of rap fan of pop
culture a little bit of him is like this
is so cool that i'm in a kanye west song
wouldn't you think it's cool you guys
absolutely totally i would love for
kanye west to write a song oh just put
me in a lyric or whatever as long as
especially he says he's going to beat my
my booty yeah beat my butt yeah
i mean that's not nice but i'll take it
because now i'm beefing with kanye and
even though i can't rap and i'm thinking
pete's thinking the same thing like
we're stand-up comics what can you say
in response you're not gonna go in the
studio i think he handled it the right
way because the alternative is to be
like ice kayamma meet you in the studio
i'm gonna meet you on the street i think
pete will lose both battles
[Music]